a menacing military might surrounding
ukraine is only growing more threatening
as the bella russian defense ministry
performs an about face announcing
russian military drills will be extended
we believe that putin has made his
decision
period belarus claims it to be a
response to ukrainian aggression but
western leaders are rife with concern
the plan that we're seeing
is for something that could be really
the biggest war in europe since 1945.
after weeks of shuttle diplomacy failed
to make any breakthroughs
there's a renewed sense of urgency that
could see the white house and kremlin
speaking again my job as a diplomat is
to leave absolutely no stone and turn to
see if we can prevent a war there are
fears a pretext for invasion is already
being drafted the u.s embassy in russia
issuing an alert citing the potential
for attacks in major centers and near
the ukraine border while russian-backed
rebels are alleged to be opening fire in
breakaway regions in the east blaming
ukraine the west has threatened
wide-ranging consequences but only in a
reactive manner these are some of the
greatest sanctions if not the the
strongest that we've ever issued with
russia's president holding his cards
against his chest the white house
national security council met on sunday
to better understand how an attack could
unfold i think you have to look at every
possibility which is what we what we do
intelligence has been laid there for
weeks announcing russian moves before
they're played a move experts call novel
but risky if you keep saying russians
are going to invade the russians are
going to invade and they don't then of
course it
dilutes your own credibility as far as
intelligence reveals are concerned
russia has repeatedly said it has no
intentions of invading ukraine calling
predicted dates of provocation but with
u.s reports now suggesting that the
kremlin may be ready to move in western
anxiety is palpable